canner bonjour bonjour vous êtes le chef
de fil des socialistes au Sénat
président du groupe socialiste ici à la
Chambre haute du parlement un mot sur
ces trois motions qui ont été déposées
par les groupes de gauche et qui ont été
logiquement rejetées qu'est-ce que vous
aviez essayé de faire c'était de dire
que c'était pas le moment d'examiner un
projet de immigration c'est ce qu'on a
compris dans ce qu' dit Madame de La
Gonterie chaque groupe de gauche a posé
une motion ou de renvoi ou d'evabilité
ou une question préalable donc c'est un
exercice qui peut paraître fort
mais qui permet finalement d'exprimer
déjà d'entrer de jeu avant même la
discussion générale de d'exprimer nos
réserve sur sur ce texte sa construction
et les objectifs qu'il sous-entend oui
il il y a des choses que sur lesquell
vous tenez la gauche sénatorielle vous
avez fait une conférence de presse ce
matin avec vos alliés écologistes avec
vos alliés communistes notamment sur
l'article 3 l'article 4 aussi sur le
maintien de l'Ame c'est des choses sur
lesquelles vous avez mis des lignes
rouges vous à gauche oui vous savez
finalement quand on demande le maintien
de l'aide médicale d'État pour des
raisons de santé publique pour les plus
défavorisés des personnes sur notre
territoire quand on demande l'article 3
c'està-dire la régularisation par le
travail de celles et ceux qui ont
décideré de vivre en France dans les
métiers en tenstion dans les métiers en
tenstion mais on ira un peu plus loin
nous-même he parce que nous estimons que
la liste potentielle est trop trop
courte qu'est-ce que nous disons nous
envoyons un message non pas de l'xisme
mais un message finalement
d'accompagnement d'une histoire
française la France est une terre
d'immigration nous le savons bien et
d'intégration et nous voulons trouver
cet équilibre entre une immigration
contrôlée mais qui une fois qu'elle est
là soit parfaitement accompagné et
intégré dans notre pays et ce matin
lorsque vous avez réuni la presse pour
faire cette conférence de presse avec
écologistes communistes c'était
d'essayer de peser dans ce dialogue qui
penche beaucoup pour l'exécutif avec les
LR on peut le dire aussi Esser de de
dire au gouvernement qu'il faut faire
attention aussi au volet intégration qui
a peut-être été oublié ces derniers mois
selon vous oui il vous a pas échappé que
monsieur lopt a complètement disparu du
débat public pas là aujourd'hui il n'est
pas là euh on n'entend plus sur le sujet
c'est vraiment maintenant devenu un
texte régalien porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald daranin et nous nous
demandons un équilibre et nous voulons
que l'équilibre qui avait été suscité
encouragé depuis le départ dans ce texte
ne soit pas sacrifié sur le tel d'un
accord entre l'exécutif et la droite
sénatoriale et bien merci merci pour
cette réaction au micro de Public Sénat
nous